i don't regard compassion as a virtue
compassion is a reflex not a virtue
you don't think judicious compassion is
a virtue wait wait a minute wait a
minute compassion can come deep
from the human heart and the human mind
i think are we talking about the same
kind of compassion yes trying to
understand the suffering treating adults
like infants is not virtuous i i see but
you're you're
well compassion isn't treating
adults like i mean those are just terms
are you sure okay
whatever the term is maybe you eat love
love
compassion is
i mean i i suppose i'm speaking to love
you don't think
those ideas came from
compassion
you don't think love is a blend of
compassion and encouragement and truth
love is complicated man yeah if i love
you
if i love you is it compassion or
encouragement you want from me
yeah it's a dance love is definitely a
dance of two to humans ultimately that
leads to the growth of both well that's
the thing the growth element is crucial
yeah
because the growth element to foster the
growth element that requires
judgment compassion and judgment well
even
and have been conceptualized this way
forever two hands of god mercy and
justice
they have to operate in tandem right and
mercy is
flawed as you are
you're acceptable
it's like well do you want that do you
want your flaws to be acceptable
and the answer to that is no it's so
it's like well that's where the judgment
comes in it's like but you could be
better you could be more than you are
and that's the maternal and the paternal
in some fundamental sense
and there has to be a
active
exchange of information between those
two polls
you